hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i want to give some thoughts
right now on how you could become
financially free
by june the 21st why by june 21st
because that is the date
when lockdown is supposed to be
completely over and
you know people are excited about june
21st they're thinking when the lockdown
ends
you know we're going to do that it's
going to be summer and it's going to be
fantastic let's hope that it does
but then ultimately it's going to be
summer and the knockdown's going to be
ended
but then actually for some people that
just means back to work
right third is going to end um
everything's going to end stamp duty
holiday is going to end
at the end of june so how can you right
now
maximize on march
april may and june four months how can
you become
financially independent in the next four
months and this is by the way this is
actually there's never been a better
time to do it
because number one you've got the
motivation number two you've got the
deadline
number three there's the opportunity the
property market's booming right now
and if you know exactly what you're
doing you can take advantage of that
many people have done it many people
have done it before yeah okay it took me
four years to become financially free
but how many of my students have become
financially free in just
four months loads so if i was going to
become financially free in four months
right let's say right now you might have
a few thousand pounds maybe you haven't
maybe you've got nothing
and you want to be in a situation where
by june 21st
you don't have to go to work firstly
what is financial freedom
well when i say financial freedom what
i'm talking about is i'm saying that you
just don't have to work
so you've got an income coming in from
property every month
that will replace your job
that will cover the money's gonna cover
your living expenses
so how much is that well the average
salary is about two thousand pound a
month
so if you're making two to three
thousand pounds a month
every month coming in then technically
you don't need a job
so how are you going to do that well how
i would do that
right now in 2021 i would do that
through
rent to rent that's how i would do it
and
a lot of people are thinking are renting
events still really working now
is it already a thing now and here's the
answer it absolutely
is rent to rent because hmos
across the uk whatever you think
if you go on spare room don't credit uk
hmos
are popping right now what what what do
i mean what do i mean by that
everyone's moving house a lot of people
are downsizing
people are getting divorced so people
are wanting to
have affordable accommodation they're
moving out of small apartments and
moving into a rented room
where the bills are all included now
what about what about social distancing
or hmo's
not a little bit tough because of social
distancing so you want a hmo
to have ensuites in it so it's a
self-contained room
with an ensuite shower and toilet if
you've got a room like that
if you've got a room that you own or
control
that's near a city center or a large
town center
that's self-contained right now in june
2021
you're gonna rent it out and you're
gonna rent it out between 400
and 500 pounds per month okay now
houses are renting out for like six
seven hundred pound a month
so all you need to do is you need to
find a house
that's got four or five rooms with
ensuites
now rather than finding an existing um
so rather than finding a property that
could be a hmo
what i would suggest you do is i would
suggest that you find an existing hmo
whereby the landlord is tired the
landlord might be worried
the landlord might be stressed the
landlord might be overseas
the landlord so so what are you going to
do
i would go on spare room spare room.uk
i would look at all the properties on
spare room and i would find the ones
whereby the properties the rooms are
tired
okay the rooms are tired maybe the
bedding is not great
it looks tired and i would then contact
the landlord
and i would say to the landlord hey how
would you feel about receiving a
guaranteed monthly rent
i know you're renting this property out
by the room but how would you feel about
me my company renting it from you
on a guaranteed monthly rent and some
levels will go no
i'm all good thanks if you speak to a
landlord because he's a bit tired he's
got a bit of a tired property
shabby beds not marketing it well trying
to do it himself
doing it wrong and you just say hey
you've got five rooms there but you're
only renting out two
you're only getting 800 a month and you
having to pay the bills
right now you're only making a few
hundred pound a month how about this
i'll pay you
500 pounds a month i'll pay the bills
i'll give you guaranteed rent i'll give
you a thousand pound up front
i mean you only have to keep you only
have to keep asking the question
you get one landlord that says yes then
you're gonna pay me 500 pounds
you're gonna rent the rooms out for 400
400 400 400
400 now if the landlord couldn't rent
the room is that why will you rent the
rooms out
because some landlords are doing it
wrong they don't know how to put they
don't know how to create an add-on spare
room
they don't know that tenants need super
fast wi-fi
they're trying to cut corners they're
bedding they don't they don't put
nice pictures with nice bedding and and
a mirror in the room
so all you have to do is make some small
changes from ikea
that can cost 500 pounds and then
suddenly
you can be making between 500 and 1000
pounds
profit per month per rental rent
property that you've got
so what i would do is i would just get
three or four of those
in your local city center
wherever the closest city center is
three or four of those that's gonna be
giving you a profit of about two
two and a half thousand pounds a month
now if you haven't got any money at all
to start with
i would package deals and i would sell
them to investors
find properties that are below market
value or
find properties that could be potential
development opportunities
potential bar refurbished opportunities
get the skills
view them find them investors right now
are going crazy for good deals
if you can find a good deal you can sell
it on you can make two thousand pounds
so i'll be doing deal selling alongside
rent to rents
i'd be going crazy i'd be like look it's
by june 21st
i haven't got four rent to rents
making me 2 000 pounds minimum and if
i'm not able to package and sell a deal
making me 2 000 pounds minimum then i
die that's how i would act
and then by june 21st 2021 you're gonna
be you're gonna be packaging and selling
one deal a month
you're gonna have a few rental rents
giving you two thousand pound a month
are you gonna be rich no are you gonna
have to be able to line the beach
forever no
but are you gonna have to go and work at
a job come june 21st no
you're going to be full-time in property
and that is what i would do to become
financially free
and then geez but by the time that
happens then you can set a new plan
then you can say right now my plan is i
want to stop building my own portfolio i
want to start
joint venturing on deals i want to turn
some of my rental rents
into lease option agreements we have the
right to buy them you can worry about
that
in the summer but right now just find
the the strength right now and the
motivation
to do whatever it takes to get yourself
in a position
by june 21st where you do not have to go
and get a job
anyway i hope you found it helpful um
smash the like
button subscribe and i'm going to be
doing videos every single day on youtube
giving you content helping you so that
you can do this you know working with
you along the way
if you want to join me at the property
investors crash course it's a free
live with me and i'll leave a link in
the description below
where you can join me for free on the
house subscribe
get books on the crash course check out
more videos
thanks so much for watching